my first initial reaction when I read
this was this is brave this is original
this is unique I need to get out of a
toxic relationship
[Music]
you have the most narcissistic boss
imaginable who is also a powerful
blood-sucking vampire
marvelous attire the codependency is
toxic but there's a level of Love there
okay feeding you're like the guy that
gets the villains Postmates is it yummy
or an action and Comedy All existing in
one movie we are punching heads up
blood correct tasers fireworks
and then you get me looking like this
being an absolute Maniac people love
heart but what's gonna really pull them
into this is the humor and as they're
laughing
[Music]
you can hit that Bullseye of comedy and
horror
you've got something quite special quite
delicious
come on